This website has done over $600,000
in 6 months. That's $100,000
a month in revenue strictly from SEO.
Let's go ahead and break it down and
show you how you can drive more revenue
using SEO. In the last 30 days, they got
about 76,000 active users. So, each day
they're getting about, you know, 2,500
uh 3,000 users every single day going
over to their website. Now, if you
actually go ahead and did some math on
this client, as you can see here, we're
very conversion optimized. So, there's a
pop-up that allows you to be able to get
your information,
which goes directly over to the
receptionist that can then book in an
order. Also, if you go over to contact,
you can then go ahead
and book in a free consultation. Let's
go ahead and do some quick math. So,
let's say over 600,000 people have
visited the site in the past 6 months.
Let's say out of those uh 670 76,000
people, only 7% 7% of the people put
their information into the form.
So, let's say again out of those
inquiries that put their information in,
only 5%. So, 0.05
5% of them actually um are qualified
leads that can do a procedure. Now, out
of the 2,366
people that were booked, you know,
show-up rates can vary. So, let's say
out of the 2,300 people that booked,
let's say only 50% of them actually show
up to their appointment. So, that leaves
us with 1,183.
Now, when someone shows up at an
appointment, the chance of them closing
is much much higher. So, let's say out
of this, 80% of them actually go ahead
and do a procedure. So, we're going to
times that by 0.80.
So, we're left with 946
booked appointments. Now, for this
specific client, their procedures range
very high between 600 and up to like
2,000. So, let's just go ahead with 750
as a nice medium. So, we can see here
from $750
a procedure going all the way down from,
you know, to 946 people, they still made
a little bit shy under a million dollars
just from SEO. And these are very, very
conservative numbers. In my opinion,
they probably could be higher than this.
We also have another client that we work
with and we've just worked with them for
the past couple of months and they're
already getting over 236
clicks to their website. They have a low
ticket item that sells pretty quickly.
So, let's say out of 263 clicks, let's
just say again, 10% of those buy, right?
So, very, very low, so about 26 people
at an average price of $100, they're
making about $2,630
per month from SEO without doing any
additional work. And this is going to
continue to grow. So, SEO, as you guys
know, is the best converting traffic
because people are ready to buy. They
already have intent. If they find you on
Google, they will most likely buy from
you. We've gotten a lot of inquiries
about doing done-for-you packages. So,
based on our results and based upon some
openings that we have, we are working
with a select number of clients. So, if
you're looking to get your SEO boosted
to get more revenue from SEO, that is
something that we're well versed in. As
you can see, these are some of our case
studies and we have some other websites
that we can't really talk about
publicly. But you can go ahead and take
a look at these screenshots. These are
all real screenshots and you guys
actually see me building a lot of these
sites and growing a lot of the SEO on
this channel. So, if you want to see
Inquirer, our SEO program is very, very
affordable. It starts at $500 just
depending on the scope of what you need.
So, So more customizable. I don't like
to say it's going to be, you know, this
price. It really depends on what you
need. So we can do the SEO for you,
fully hands-off for you. We could also
go ahead and build websites for you. So
if you needed a website for your
specific business, we can go ahead and
build a beautiful
SEO optimized what website. So we're not
necessarily using Rank Site because Rank
Site is a little bit more rigid in its
design. So we'll design you a custom
website that you can use for yourselves.
So these are the two latest sites that
we generated for two clients. So you can
go ahead and take a look at that if you
want a website done. Websites are pretty
affordable. We can get it done and we
can get it done pretty quickly. So the
best part about all of this that I
mentioned is that you can work with us
for done-for-you, but we've actually
went ahead and created two products that
I'm sure you've seen, which is Word
Rocket and Rank Site. So both of these
tools is what I've used to fuel the
growth of these two SEO
strategy. So we use Word Rocket to
generate high-quality, in-depth content,
which brings us a lot of traffic. The
blog post is what brings in the bulk of
their
traffic and users. We use Word Rocket on
a daily basis and we automate the
content creation to our clients and that
does really, really well. As you can
see, the content actually gets cited by
AI and it shows up in Chat GPT and it
also brings in qualified leads. We also
have Rank Site. If you wanted to build a
website on your own, you can use Rank
Site to build a SEO optimized website
that you can grow, you can index, and
that you can get qualified leads to. So
you don't have to use our done-for-you
service. You can go ahead and use the
tools that we've built. Hope that you
guys enjoyed this one. I'll see you in
the next video. If you want to try out
any of our tools
or inquire for our done-for-you service,
there'll be links below this video. Hope
that you enjoyed this one. I'll see you
in the next one. Take care.